sometimes it's good to sort of step back
a little bit and add some context to
some of these fast-moving stories that
will consume the new cycle for 24 hours
or 48 hours or in the case of the
sending back chance at a North Carolina
Trump rally it's really been almost like
a two week or 10 or 12 day story in
total so remember last week at a rally
in North Carolina Donald Trump mentioned
congresswoman Olano Maher the crowd
starts chanting send her back here's a
quick reminder of what that was like
and she talked about the evil Israel so
this completely implodes on Trump it
creates really almost like five
uninterrupted days of criticism of the
White House which was in full damage
control mode almost immediately found
out about this from The Washington Post
article with 26 sources about Trump
didn't even really seem to understand
what it was that was problematic about
what went down and what he said and how
he reacted and what he tweeted so
eventually it got through to Trump that
you probably want to distance yourself
from the chant at least so Trump took
the position of I didn't like the chant
and in fact as is always the case with
Trump he goes too far he could say in
retrospect I didn't like the chant but
he goes too far and says I tried to stop
it right away
I made super clear that I didn't like
the chant in the moment which of course
if you look at the video is not clear
whatsoever check out what he said again
this is just meaningless damage control
Donald Trump trying to say anything that
at the time seems like it might help him
and he says all sorts of stuff that just
isn't true including that he started
talking very quickly so MSNBC did a side
by side with a counter showing exactly
how long it was that Trump was silent as
the chant continued take a look chanting
send her back why don't you stop well
number one I think I did I started
speaking very quickly
it really was a that I disagree with it
by the way but it was quite
and I felt a little bit badly about it
but I'm going to say this I did and I
started speaking very quickly but it
started out rather rather fast as you
probably know okay so he's telling us he
didn't like the chant the chant was bad
so he claims
but then Trump says well I didn't like
the chant but the people chanting are
great people and are great Patriots
where did we hear this before here's
Donald Trump not on the chant but on the
chanters I'm unhappy with the fact that
a congresswoman in this case a different
congresswoman can call our country and
our people garbage that's what I'm
unhappy with those people in North
Carolina that stadium was packed it was
a record crowd and I could have filled
it 10 times as you know those are
incredible people those are incredible
Patriots but I'm unhappy when a
congresswoman goes and said I'm gonna be
the president's nightmare by the way
Trump said it was a record crowd what
does that even mean at this point
obviously not true a demonstrable lie
one that Trump often likes to tell but
there was nothing record-breaking about
the crowd whatsoever no matter how you
measure it but the important thing here
is Trump says almost back to back he
didn't like the chant he tried to stop
the chant he resumed his speech quickly
to interrupt the chant all of which are
not true but then he also says the
people in the crowd doing the chanting
those are great people
those are patriots how does this compute
the chant was disgusting and terrible
the people who came up with the chant
truly lovely great Patriots these are
the sorts of contradictions that come up
when the president's word means nothing
I mean truly nothing murder is
absolutely disgusting it's terrible I
don't know why anyone would ever commit
such a horrible act but that roomful of
murderers those are great people I mean
truly lovely patriotic great people the
murders themselves though I disagree
with what are you talking about what are
you talking about and it almost is like
a philosophical discussion which
couldn't possibly be what Donald Trump
is trying to stimulate
here because the guy has no clue about
philosophy whatsoever it's it's more
like a reverse double down send her back
looks pleased in the moment lets it go
on reaction to send her back his
disastrous for Trump he says I didn't
like the chant I interrupted the chant
quickly which isn't true
but then it gets us to say oh okay so
you're upset with the people who were
chanting right because he didn't like
the chant oh no the problems not the
people the people were great it was a
record sized crowd full of Patriots but
the chant is what I disagree with for
all of the opposition to post-modernism
that this new right claims to have they
sure to seem seem to see language and
words as having completely malleable
fluid meaning that can be shaped like
clay to mean or not mean whatever it is
that's convenient to them at the time
complete and utter contradiction if you
care about double standards if you care
about consistency you're probably
already not voting for Donald Trump